MICROSOFT’S PROFIT MARGINS:
Have you noticed that Microsoft has fallen
out of the spotlight?
Compared to their tech peers, Microsoft is
rarely on the news and not many people have
a strong opinion about the company.
In fact, I’d argue that Micorsoft is the
prominent tech company that people don’t
have a strong opinion about.
With Apple, there’s the whole controversy
about their premium pricing and their anti
user policies.
With Facebook and Google, you’ve got the
entire privacy argument.
With Amazon, you’ve got the bald slave driver
controversy.
And with Netflix, well a lot of people are
happy that they’re getting crushed.
This isn’t to say that we aren’t dependent
on Microsoft though.
The vast majority of the world still uses
windows and even if you’re a mac user, you
probably still use microsoft office.
Yet, despite their popularity, we rarely talk
about Microsoft as a company.
I mean, they’re literally not even part
of FAANG and their public interest is virtually
non existent in comparison to FAANG.
Despite this, Microsoft’s business as a
whole is doing better than ever.
In fact, their gross margins are nearly 70%
and their net margins are nearly 40%.
If Apple had these margins, people would be
shredding them to pieces, but because it’s
Microsoft, no one cares or even knows other
than shareholders.
Last year, Microsoft even overtook Apple and
became the world’s most valuable company
for a hot minute.
If this same thing happened with Amazon instead
of Microsoft, we would’ve seen social media
erupt with outrage and toxicity, yet no one
cares because it was Microsoft.
Somehow, they’ve essentially become the
VISA of the tech space.
Everyone knows about them and uses them on
a regular basis, but no one cares about them
much more than that.
Honestly, this is probably the ideal situation
given that spotlight the hasn’t exactly
been forgiving historically.
But, how has the company that essentially
created the modern computer experience been
able to avoid the spotlight so effectively.
Well, it’s definitely not by accident.
So, here’s how Microsoft became the world’s
largest background company.
THE PUBLIC MONOPOLY:
Taking a look back, Microsoft wasn’t always
such a discrete business.
In the 80s and 90s, Microsoft was very much
a consumer business and that’s why we all
know about them today.
As a front facing company, they faced much
of the same criticism that today’s top tech
companies are subject to.
Many thought that Microsoft was a gross monopoly
and that Bill Gates was an ruthless businessman.
Bill’s social image at the time could be
compared to that of Mark Zuckerberg’s today.
But, Bill didn’t really care.
He was the richest man in the world and Microsoft
was more profitable than ever, so he wasn’t
going to let a bit of public criticism get
to his head.
But, maybe, he should’ve paid more attention
to the criticism because pretty soon regulators
got involved.
In 1992, the Federal Trade Commision would
began an inquiry into Microsoft’s monopoly.
This quickly escalated into a DOJ investigation,
and in 1994, the DOJ would order that Microsoft
was no longer allowed to package other Microsoft
products with the sale of Windows.
However, one nuance to these decree was that
Microsoft could continue packaging in additional
features with Windows.
It probably would’ve been in Microsoft’s
best interest to play this safe and avoid
testing the regulators.
But, Microsoft had different plans.
The internet was starting to explode in popularity,
and it was clear to Microsoft that the internet
was the next big thing.
So, what better way to capitalize on the internet
than to launch a browser, and this lead to
the creation of Internet Explorer in 1995.
If Microsoft stopped right there, it wouldn’t
have been that bad.
Sure, they were still pushing the boundaries
of being a computer software monopoly, but
they weren’t violating any court decrees
right?
Well, this was true at the beginning, but
this didn’t last long.
It was clear to Microsoft that if they really
wanted to make Internet Explorer popular,
they had to package in with Windows.
So, they would call Internet Explorer a feature
and throw it in with Windows.
As you would guess, regulators weren’t exactly
a fan of this classification.
Internet Explorer was obviously a product
and Microsoft was simply calling it a feature
to try to get around the DOJ settlement.
At first, the regulators turned a blind eye
to this, but Microsoft kept pushing the envelope.
Remember the controversy about Apple slowing
down older iPhones, well, Microsoft had their
own version of this with Internet Explorer.
They told users and the court that if the
browser was uninstalled, Windows would run
slower and have more malfunctions.
This was obviously completely false, and if
Windows did slow down, it was because Microsoft
programmed it to slow down, not because Internet
Explorer actually made Windows run better.
Eventually, regulators had enough, and in
1998, they would put their foot down.
The DOJ and the Attorny Generals of 20 US
states and the District of Columbia would
sue Microsoft for “illegally thwarting competition
in order to protect and extend its software
monopoly.”
SAVING THE MONOPOLY:
Usually, it takes forever for regulators to
get involved, but once they’re involved,
you know they mean business.
Two perfect examples of this were Standard
Oil and AT&T.
In 1911, Standard Oil was broken up into 34
different companies.
And in 1984, AT&T was split up into 8 different
companies.
A break up like this would’ve devastated
Microsoft and Bill knew it.
Fortunately for Microsoft though, Bill had
already been preparing to fight such a lawsuit.
You see, several months before the lawsuit,
Microsoft had actually bailed out Apple.
If you’re familiar with Apple’s history,
you know that they were getting destroyed
in the late 1990s and the company was on the
brink of bankruptcy.
Even though Microsoft could’ve easily watched
from the sidelines as Apple went bankrupt,
Bill decided to strike a deal with Steve instead.
Steve agreed to drop Apple’s copyright lawsuit
against Microsoft and Bill agreed to invest
$150 million into Apple.
Through this deal, not only was Bill able
to knock out Apple’s lawsuit against them,
but he was able to create some plausible deniability
for himself.
If regulators questioned him about his monopolistic
practices, Bill could point to how he saved
Apple and how he’s actually pro competition.
Unfortunately though, regulators didn’t
quite buy Bill’s master plan and on June
7, 2000, they ordered that Microsoft be broken
up into two separate units.
One unit would produce operating systems while
the other would produce additional software.
Honestly, this ruling wasn’t even that bad
given that AT&T was broken up into 8 parts
and Standard oil was broken up into 34 parts.
But, that doesn’t mean that Microsoft was
happy with the verdict.
They weren’t gonna go down without a fight,
so they filed an appeal.
The appeal was instantly escalated to the
Supreme Court, and the justices would suprisingly
all side with Microsoft but not for the reason
that you would think.
The supreme court unanimously agreed that
Microsoft was absolutely a monopoly; however,
they invalidated the break up order because
the judge who issued the order did not follow
the correct protocols.
He had failed to hold hearings on the remedy
and he had also been having secret interviews
with reporters while the case was ongoing.
The supreme court did not rule out the possibility
of properly issuing another breakup order,
but after being so publicly humiliated, it’s
no wonder why prosecutors didn’t pursue
another breakup order.
Instead, they would order that Microsoft share
their application programming interface with
third party companies and that a panel be
setup to ensure Microsoft’s compliance.
Microsoft had basically just won the lottery.
They were able to avoid a gamechanging breakup
all thanks to a few semantics.
Playing ball as a brash public monopoly had
nearly devastated Microsoft, and Microsoft
had escaped with the skin of their teeth.
There was no way that Steve Ballmer or Bill
were gong let this happen to Microsoft again.
And this marked the beginning of Microsoft's
life in a shell.
TRANSITION TO B2B:
There was no question that Microsoft needed
to stop attracting all of this public interest
if they wanted to avoid future lawsuits and
regulations.
But, how does such a massive company fade
from the spotlight?
Well, the answer is switching customers.
Microsoft has always had an extremely lose
policy when it comes to people pirating their
software.
In fact, Bill has publicly admitted that Microsoft
would rather you use a pirated version of
their software than a pirated or paid version
of someone else’s software.
As you can see, Bill was very much ok with
people pirating their software if it meant
Microsoft would get more marketshare.
As Bill touched on, the idea was that they
could eventually figure out some sort of method
of monetization whether that be ads or data
collection.
By the mid 2000s, Windows and Office had basically
reached market saturation, so it was finally
time to collect.
But, they couldn’t deploy something as public
as ads or data collection.
Regulators were literally waiting for the
next moment that Microsoft would trip up so
that they could persue more severe legal action.
So, directly monetizing customers was off
the table, but it was time to look at monetization
differently.
Instead of trying to monetize the end user
directly, maybe it was smarter to monetize
businesses.
They had already gotten people used to and
addicted to Microsoft products, so they could
force businesses, institutions, and computer
manufacturers to pay for Windows and Office.
They also went ahead and basically made Windows
free for end users.
So, no one could really complain.
Everyday people weren’t directly paying
Microsoft at all.
And, institutions had better things to do
than complain about Microsoft leveraging their
monopoly and charging insane markups.
I gotta say, there was legitimate reason to
complain if they wanted to though.
Back in 2010, Microsoft literally had gross
margins above 80%.
Meanwhile, the regulators didn’t really
care because they only care about protecting
the public not institutions.
They figure that institutions have the resources
and capital to protect themselves if they
wanted to.
And given that the public wasn’t being harmed,
regulators turned a blind eye once again.
Not to mention, they had bigger fish to fry
like Facebook, Google, and Amazon who were
even more obvious monopolies.
So, Microsoft has been more or less left to
do as the please when it comes to the computer
OS market.
THE NEW MICROSOFT:
Overtime, Microsoft has further leaned into
this B2B model and they’ve started to offer
these businesses other products like servers
and cloud computing.
Since then, this side business has grown so
much that it’s actually started to outshine
Windows and Office.
In fact, intelligent cloud is now Microsoft’s
largest revenue driver having pulled in $20.9
billion last quarter.
This includes all of their server products
and cloud services.
Second place goes to the productivity and
business processes category which pulled in
$16.6 billion.
This includes Microsoft Office, LinkedIn,
and other commercial products.
And in last place, we have the personal computing
category which pulled in $14.4 billion and
this is what includes Windows, the XBox, Bing,
and other consumer products.
This means that Microsoft could completely
ditch the consumer market, and their business
would only shrink 30% if that.
In other words, they could ditch the consumer
business and they’d likely still be a trillion
dollar company.
And that right there is why Microsoft has
completely avoided the spotlight.
In the 80s and 90s, Microsoft was one of the
most well known consumer businesses in the
world, but after nearly being broken up, they
made a 180.
They pivoted to being an institutional business
which allowed them to maintain their monopoly
with little public criticism and legal ramifcations.
And now that they’ve made the switch, they
no longer need or want public attention.
For them, it’s better if the media keeps
grilling on Facebook and Google while Microsoft
continues making just as much from the shadows.
And that's why Microsoft has been avoiding
the spotlight.
Did you realize what game Microsoft was playing?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you can’t help but
respect the strategy.
And of course, consider checking out our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.